last-minute preparations are taking
place here it's in Peter's Church in
McCulloch for a service that will very
much reflect the life and the tastes of
five-year-old April herself that she has
featured a photograph of fur is featured
on the front of the order of service a
photograph of April enjoying a day out
in the seaside not far away from her
hometown also on that order of service a
message from paul and coral her parents
and the rest of the family saying that
what they described as the overwhelming
kindness sympathy and support during
this sad sad time the cortege will
arrive at the church just before a
twelve o'clock noon which will have come
from the estate of Bryn agog where April
used to live it'll be a horse-drawn
carriage carrying the coffin and it's
only recently actually that the family
knew that they would be able to hold a
proper traditional funeral and say a
proper goodbye to April because the
inquest was only held recently and the
decision was made that they could
release the fragments of bone which is
all that was found of April following
the extensive police investigation the
service will include poems written by
local writers and read by April's
teachers from the school that she used
to attend and all the donations will go
towards sponsoring the education of a
little girl in Uganda via the charity
world vision Paul and coral April's
parents wanted there to be something
very good and positive to come out of
this very sad day